Taste is an important sense, so why is it
that some animals have such a screwed up palate?
Hey there friends, Trace here for DNews.
Bacon is one of the great foods of the carnivorous
world, but whales can't taste it.
Pie is another fantastic food and dolphins
can't taste it...
Oranges?
Nope.
ICE CREAM CAKE?!
NO!?!
I weep for their childhoods.
Firstly, pretty much every vertebrate has
the ABILITY -- genetically speaking -- to
taste things, and molecularly, they should
taste in the same way we taste.
But not all organisms need to taste every
type of food, and thus they lose some tastes
as they evolved.
Many invertebrates like insects and even microorganisms
have evolved cells which have a sense like
taste, for the same reasons as us, because
they want to make sure the food their ingesting
is good for them!
Smell and taste are the oldest senses because
they facilitate the testing of food and determine
if it's safe to eat.
Herbivores have the most taste buds, so they
don't eat toxic plants.
Carnivores have the least, because unless
they're eating poison frogs, they don't really
need a lot of flavor in their uncooked meat
diet.
Omnivores eat both, so we get a lot of taste
buds too.
Whales however, USED to be able to taste things,
but not anymore says a new study in Genome
Biology and Evolution.
So, what had happened was, 53 million years
ago, whales and dolphins split into two groups
-- cetaceans with teeth and those without.
Turns out, if you just swallow food and don't
chew, you probably won't need taste buds.
Therefore slowly over generations they lost
the molecular receptors to detect sweet, bitter,
umami, and sour.
Today, they only taste salty flavors!
The researchers tested the genomes of 15 species
of whale and dolphin and the taste genes were
present, but were heavily mutated.
As the mutations increased the genes of these
species slowly become less and less expressed,
until they end up with pseudogenes.
It's sort of like somewhere a gene USED to
be... they can still see in the genome, but
it doesn't develop in the fully grown organism.
Remember, taste isn't purely about enjoyment,
it's also a way for us to determine nutritional
content in food and sense poisons or rot.
So now that humans are in the mix, this lack
of flavor can be damaging to these ocean-bound
creatures.
Without being able to sense flavors, whales
have unknowingly wandered into contaminated
waters.
The researchers think the whales and dolphins
kept salty flavors due to a need to maintain
an intake of salt to maintain blood pressure
and sodium levels.
But large swimming mammals aren't the only
ones to lose some taste.
Lions, asian otters, hyenas, some seals, housecats
and other primarily carnivorous mammals lost
the sense of taste millions of years ago,
also due to genetic mutation.
Because these animals are mainly carnivorous,
they don't care how many sweets and carbs
they ingest, and over time lost the ability
to taste them!
Fish have lots of taste buds, some are even
on the outside of their skin.
REptiles pick up air molecules with their
tongue and runs it across the Jacobson's Organ
on the roof of their mouth to pick up tastes
and smells.
Some birds, like parrots and cockatiels have
a ton of taste receptors with the cockatiel
being able to sense salt, sugar and acid -- but
in general birds only have a few... like chickens,
they've only got 30 buds.
Poor chickens.
Poor delicious chickens.
What do you think?
Do you eat for the flavor?
The texture?
Are you one of those people who just eat for
fuel?
Tell us below in the comments and be sure
you subscribe for more DNews.
Dogs CAN taste sweet, btw.
So don't forget to check out Animalists new
show "Best Breed Ever" where they'll tell
you everything you want to know about your
favorite dog breeds.
Like, did you know golden retrievers are from
Scotland?
Subscribe to "Best Breed Ever" and learn to
love dogs more than your Instagram friends
can handle.